este sitio es muy importante porque a
caer dónde vivían mis padres cecilia
lozano interrumpe su campaña en los
departamentos del meta y guaviare en el
sur oriente de colombia visita uno de
los múltiples hogares en los que se
refugió víctima del desplazamiento
forzado volver al lugar tiene una gran
carga emocional
algún día me habrá gustado
para haber podido contarle todo
con la desaparición de su marido cecilia
paso de campesina lideresa y ya lleva 16
años ejerciendo una de las profesiones
de más riesgo en colombia uno sabe que
no lo harían pero yo me atrevo
y me atrevo
[Música]
cecilia lozano no es una candidata
normal se presentan las elecciones
legislativas del 13 de marzo en colombia
pero lo hace en los 16 escaños de la
cámara de representantes reservados para
víctimas es la primera vez en la
historia y son resultados del acuerdo de
paz entre las farc y el estado
colombiano de 2016 después de más de 5
años regresa una vereda de su municipio
mapiripán una victoria donde en 1997 se
produjo una de las peores masacres
paramilitares de colombia ya necesitaba
hablar de la coubre de paz durante más
de un mes está visitando acompañada por
su esquema de seguridad y protegida por
su sombrero todas las casas que se
encuentran en los políticos
tradicionales siempre van y dan el
discurso pero nosotros no somos
políticos de los tradicionales nosotros
somos líderes y nosotros queremos
escuchar la gente para ser la voz de las
víctimas en el congreso y ya se ha
representado y vemos el trabajo que ya
entonces mi voto debe hacer para ello el
gobierno debería financiar su campaña
con unos cinco mil dólares no ha
recibido nada por lo que solo ha podido
poner este cartel que le han regalado y
del que presume
y cuando me miraba así
yo digo fui capaz y si me siento
orgullosa de mí mismo de los pasos que
yo he dado y decir yo también puedo
pero la lucha contra el mundo de cecilia
dista de los baños de masas de otros
candidatos que buscan ocupar los escaños
para víctimas jorge tobares el caso más
paradigmático así recorrer el nororiente
de colombia por los departamentos del
cesar magdalena en la guajira son actos
de político tradicional nuestro equipo
no ha podido ponerse en contacto con el
candidato yo yo como se autodenomina es
hijo de jorge 40 el paramilitar que
comandó un ejército relacionado con
centenares de asesinatos sus rivales
víctimas de su padre han estado
denunciando falta de garantías sino que
es la misma estructura que dejó el papá
que está haciendo defendida por quienes
mantienen el poder y que ahora en épocas
electorales pues buscan mantener esta
estructura vigente es que no hay una
libre vocación es de nuestros retornos
podido llegar no solamente por el tema
de seguridad por el tema de que hay que
ayudar es donde nos dice aquí no pueden
hacer campañas que ya tenemos candidato
soy melba miguel ramírez hija de víctor
mieles ospino
trabajador de vesículas durante 35 años
en valledupar está una de las rivales
para el escaño de paz de jojo tovar
según confesó el paramilitar alias mario
el padre de éste ordenó la muerte de los
padres de melva
trabajadores incansables asesinados el
22 de julio de 1999 por jorge 40 víctor
mieles era sindicalista de nestlé y fue
candidato a la vicepresidencia de
colombia
rosita de miel es igual que melba era
educadora entrar en política tiene
costes bueno he tenido que extremar
algunas medidas de seguridad cristales
polarizados verjas medida hasta recibir
un ataque en su propia casa vinieron a
hacer estiramientos y amenazas para que
me retirara de la campaña política por
porque ya el hijo de jorge 40 era el
dueño de esta curul de paz desde
entonces viste chaleco antibalas y
cuenta con un esquema de seguridad que
le acompaña incluso cuando se dirige al
de la unidad de víctimas de la zona
encuentra fuera de la ciudad
el propio directivo haciendo el campaña
el hijo de jorge tovar no te preocupes
yo simplemente voy a hacer es la
denuncia de dónde está ubicada en estos
momentos la atención para nosotras las
verdaderas víctimas del conflicto armado
my libro el gobierno de colombia riendo
este edificio para atender víctimas es
propiedad de ana carolina vélez mujer de
jorge 40 y madre del candidato yo yo
tovar melba considera que no debería
presentarse a las elecciones no es una
víctima simplemente porque su padre fue
el máximo asesino de toda esta región no
es una víctima porque se ha usufructuado
igual que otros candidatos de la
circunscripción mi hermano ha podido ir
a la mitad de los municipios donde
podrían votar por ella pasa mucho tiempo
en valledupar donde están enterrados sus
padres pese a las dificultades quiere
luchar por las víctimas y dejar un
ejemplo a su hija y quiero que también
se actúe una de esas personas que atrás
que ha seguido mi diario vivir
y donde te puedas mirar mañana más tarde
para que no seas indiferente ante toda
esta lucha que hemos venido trabajando y
construyendo juntas yo sé que si ganas
puedes llegar a hacer muchas cosas por
las personas es el ejemplo de la lucha
de las víctimas del conflicto en
colombia y el intento de políticos
tradicionales y víctimas polémicas como
yo yo tovar de ocupar estos espacios con
el silencio